une petite
il a craché
je crois qu'il est un peu jaloux
tu l'as embrassé mais pas l'autre Jenny
hermoso visiblement amusé lorsque elle
montre la photo du baiser avec Luis Ruby
Alès à ses coéquipières cette vidéo
prise dans le car juste après la
cérémonie de clôture de la Coupe du
Monde est très partagée par le camp Ruby
Alès dans le but clair de discréditer la
thèse de l'agression sexuelle on y voit
notamment la footballeuse mimait la
scène qui fait couler tant d'encre
depuis 10 jours dites moi ce que vous
savez dites
une avocate charmante tentez de le dire
en anglais
ma sœur qui adorait et
le
la séquence est virale mais rien indique
que l'attaquante était consentante pour
autant ni les sourires ni les blagues
dans un moment de forêt permettent de
dédouaner le président déchu de la
Fédération espagnole de football et
comme toujours c'est fractures sont
générationnelles
ah non parce que regarder
[Rires]
la jeune génération dans dans ce et
celle qui ont aujourd'hui 20 ans
vous êtes très progressiste
un perdant dans la bouche
Pascal l'été au contact de des jeunes
prenez un verre d'eau là
l'été au contact de la chaîne génération
c'est très inquiétant donc c'est en fait
un énorme bus qui vous permet de vous
faire dépister contre le cancer du sein
11000 femmes de la Seine-Maritime ont
reçu une invitation pour prendre
rendez-vous dans ce même mot mobile
allez-y car je suis dans la testico
également
une étude américaine va également dans
ce sens les demandes de divorce
connaissent tant pis à la fin du mois
d'août l'autre période délicate pour les
couples c'est après les fêtes de fin
d'année ou les bonnes résolutions riment
parfois avec séparation d'ailleurs au
Royaume-Uni le premier lundi de janvier
était baptisé le jour du divorce voilà
je grimpe bien
ouais
[Musique]
ouais Jérôme
on y est presque on y est presque je
vais ramasser les pâtes par terre je
suis là dans deux minutes
et en France ce sont les femmes qui
prennent l'initiative de demander le
divorce dans 75% des cas regardez vous
allez me dire ce que ça vous rappelle
j'ai jamais rien vous dire
[Musique]
ce matin avec Demis Roussos et je lui ai
dit c'est la musique sur laquelle on est
en train avec ma femme à la mairie et
voilà
il faut jamais rien dire à Pascal comme
un air de vacances mais en prison celui
qui filme est un détenu lourdement
condamné installé dans une petite
piscine gonflable au beau milieu de sa
cellule des petits clips volontairement
provocateur
sur une musique de rap qu'il a posté
lui-même sur les réseaux sociaux il y a
quelques jours tollé dans les rangs de
l'administration pénitentiaire
comment une piscine arrive en cellule
des vidéos de colis volants dans
plusieurs prisons françaises circulent
sur les réseaux sociaux les détenus se
vantent de se faire livrer par drone
toutes sortes de marchandises
que se détenu n'en est pas à sa première
provocation porte grande ouverte le
voilà profitant d'une autre piscine avec
deux côtés tenues une séance de bain là
encore diffusée sur les réseaux sociaux
mais ça craque ça craque là
on entend
c'est la glace qui se fissure
on ne peut pas s'approcher plus ça peut
être dangereux un bloc qui tombe ça fait
voler des éclats de glace et on pourrait
être frappé par des éclats
lorsque l'ouragan Idéalia frappe les
côtes hier matin s'évant atteignent par
endroits plus de 200 km heure
soufflante ici
le toit de cette station essence
les pluies et la marée s'infiltre à
l'intérieur des terres des milliers de
maisons touchées
mais de la vogénale le bilan aurait pu
être beaucoup plus lourd oui donc si on
met si on met des morceaux de cette
glace dans son verre c'est des glaçons
qui durent plus longtemps c'est ça
l'intérêt si c'est oui ça dure plus
de temps que sa met à fondre une comparé
vous pouvez faire un business
à chaque instant vous pourriez faire un
business des des vendre dans le monde
entier les glaçons qui durent dix fois
plus longtemps
c'est sûr en plus on a de la réserve
la bulle arrive
vous allez nous la commencer
[Rires]
il n'a pas envie de rentrer merci
beaucoup vous êtes il faut pas oublier
aussi que il y a la Baya tout ce qui est
religieux
justement j'en viens les problèmes de
tenue religieuse et aussi les filles qui
les jeunes filles qui arrivent à
habiller comme des Filles de Joie de
seconde zone avec le t-shirt ici le mini
short ici bah ça règle aussi ce problème
là donc je suis vraiment pour l'uniforme
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quand il s'agit de râler ils sont
champions hors catégorie